when piers morgan was forced off the air
last month we were told it was because
he had insulted the fake duchess from
los angeles but on some level it wasn't
really about her
even about him it was about all of us
and our right to say what we think is
true in a supposedly free country it was
about free speech
and the freedom of conscience conscience
he of course is still at large a daily
mail and what he writes is still
worth reading but he's on television
right now
and again that has implications for the
freedom of speech around the world
here's part of our conversation
what i found was over five years we
trebled the ratings on good morning
print
the last day ironically was as you said
the first day we beat the bbc
ever and we had trebled our ratings so
you would have thought people might be
thanking me instead i was basically
corralled into a position
where i was told you've either got to
apologize
for effectively disbelieving meghan
markle's version of events here
or your position is untenable and you
have to leave and my gut was
i'm i was going to be damned
if i was going to apologize for
something
that i believe and i just wasn't going
to go down that road i've seen too many
people
when they're bullied by the woke brigade
into apologizing we saw it with sharon
osborne
she was bullied into apologizing for
defending me
against a disgusting slur that i'm a
racist and rather than the person who
was accusing her
apologizing to me cheryl underwood for
accusing me
falsely of being a racist sharon had to
apologize for her
passionate defense of me and then she
lost her job anyway
we saw recently the editor of teen vogue
before she could even start
she apologized for years about stuff she
tweeted
as a 17 year old kid but that wasn't
enough
so apologies don't ever get you anywhere
i don't believe meghan markle
now what i didn't know and what was a
fascinating thing to discover
after i left was that meghan markle
between the monday and tuesday had made
a personal complaint to the boss
of itv named carolyn mccall i didn't
know that i was ever told that
i don't know what pressure she was
directly putting on but she did
i know personally contact her i also
know she had personally contacted along
with
prince harry ofcon which is a government
regulatory body
designed to regulate what we put out on
news shows
so i was under attack from miss markle
uh both directly to my boss and to the
government regulatory body
under attack to basically conform to her
version of events
and i had to believe her and if i didn't
i was a callous racist
and i should be condemned and ultimately
as it turned out later that day
lose my job and i think that's a pretty
perilous slope
a journalist's job which is to express
skepticism about some of the more
outlandish claims
like the secret wedding like the story
about archie
becoming a prince and so on even down to
small stuff like she'd never
had any interest in the royals when
there were pictures of her draped over
buckingham palace railings
when she was a teenager and so on um i
should be able
to be a journalist and question the
veracity of those statements
and frankly i should be allowed in a
democracy
that values freedom of speech i should
be allowed to say
i'm sorry i don't believe you but i
wasn't
i wasn't allowed to do that it was
megan's way
and megan's narrative and megan's truth
that phrase was actually used by oprah
winfrey this is your truth
what does that mean when do we get to
your truth
this is this is the kind of defense that
it was the kind of thing we would hear
liberals attack donald trump for
for reinventing facts for creating his
own truth
but when meghan markle does it the same
liberals that attack donald trump
cheer and applaud and say this is her
truth
and it must be believed and if you don't
believe it you're a racist
well i'm sorry i'm not a racist i just
don't believe her
and no one points out the kind of
underlying irony is that here you have
two of the most powerful people in the
world in oprah winfrey and meghan markle
both claiming to be
victims they're oppressed they have more
power than you
they got you fired but you're oppressing
them
the strong pretending to be weak in
order to crush
people below them does anyone notice
this dynamic
well it's completely absurd frankly and
i've written about this regularly
for the daily mail about the ludicrous
hypocrisy
of this couple who by the way contrary
to what many americans have been led to
believe
the press coverage of these two right up
to the wedding was
you completely over-the-top euphoric
everyone in britain was thrilled that
finally we were having
uh a non-white bride in the royal family
it hadn't happened we were all
very happy about this i wrote about how
wonderful it was on the wedding day
so this narrative that from the start
she was bombarded with
horrible hateful racist press coverage
is another
disingenuous load of nonsense fueled by
the oprah winfrey show where they
flashed up a series of headlines
but really where this leaves us is that
you've got this
concept that somehow meghan markle who
married into one of the richest most
privileged families
in the world and within a couple of
years
has gone back to her home in california
is living in
an 11 million dollar mansion is doing
all sorts of enormous deals with netflix
spotify
you name it they're taking the checks
hundreds of millions we read
and how are they getting those taco
they're getting them because they're the
duke and duchess of sussex
they're getting them off their royal
titles the royal titles bestowed on them
by the very institution in the interview
with oprah winfrey
they say they they can't stand and he's
suffocating and traps them and so on and
so on
but he can't have it both ways if you
really believe that way about the royal
family and the monarchy
give up your titles but they won't do
that because it makes them too much
money
so now you have these two oppressed
people living in a mansion in california
earning hundreds of millions of dollars
in the middle of a pandemic that's
killed nearly three million people
portraying themselves as the biggest
victims in the world but there are many
people who don't have our platform
who are getting wiped out eradicated
lives destroyed careers ended
over the most ridiculous things and it's
got to stop and it will only stop
when the mass body of people who don't
feel this way
who don't find themselves offended by
absolutely everything
when they stand up and go enough i'm not
going to let this happen
the power of free speeches winston
churchill said some people think free
speech is absolutely fine right to the
point
they hear an opinion that they don't
like and then it's an outrage
that's not what free speech is free
speech is about listening to an
outrageous opinion you don't agree with
and being able to accept that somebody
else doesn't feel like you
that's what free speech is
suffering does amazing things to people
they become very different in a short
period of time in the case of
piers morgan he's gotten a lot wiser and
a lot braver and very much worth
listening to we spoke to him for over an
hour today
it's available on demand foxnation.com
if you want to watch